non-minimalists
would you say it is intentionality or
vanity if one chooses to look for
specific characteristics in a partner
such as height hair color or other
physical traits to provide an attraction
as a person who enjoys the act of sex
and the intimate intimacy that sex
provides is important to me that my
partner's beliefs about intimacy align
with my own beliefs
a relationship lacking intimacy simply
won't be fulfilling for me it's me there
is a physical component to attraction
and it would be difficult for me to be
intimate with a partner i'm not
attracted to physically
on some level and yet we're often told
that looks don't matter
it's what's inside the couch this makes
me feel guilty for
initially choosing partners based on who
i have in a sexual attraction to
all this seems possible if i follow this
age all advice i might end up feeling
unfulfilled
i'm old enough to know that a person's
physical characteristics are not
everything in a relationship
but can it be a factor in the equation
and get things started
or must be i'll be social pariahs for
having a preference
so chris i mean i think it has to be
part of the equation i mean
unless you're asexual which is
definitely a thing
but but if you want to be an intimate
relationship with someone having a
an attraction now what our attraction
strategy is is different for each of us
can you talk a little bit about about
jerome's question here
yeah i think i think a mistake that
people often make is conflating
attraction
with um uh
compatibility in a long-term
relationship right
i think it's important to disentangle
those and sort of think about them
as separate issues
[Music]
because physical attraction as
jerome said can sort of get it started
can draw you to someone chemistry yeah
but often chemistry is the result
of psychological incompatibility
right i think a lot of times what we do
in relationships is we choose a partner
who
will sort of draw
us toward
issues that we have trouble with
and so that can be a source of growth
because
you're drawn to these issues that you're
troubled by
and you can work through them maybe
yeah or you just keep banging your head
against them and you have one of these
like dramatic but crazy relationships
that a lot of people
get into which can be sexually really
fulfilling
right the makeup sex can be amazing all
the yelling and screaming and breaking
things can get really hot if you're
you know that kind of person um but i
think that
it's important to sort of disentangle
those things because
the attraction will fade over time as
you become
family you know you you live with
someone for 10 years they become a
sibling right
i don't care how hot they are yeah as
the level of familiarity
increases the the the level of
physical chemistry often decreases right
and and again that's one of those things
that people often blame themselves for
or think that's
it you know they're told that there's
something wrong with their relationship
because
every month cosmo has 10 more tricks for
keeping it hot in bed forever you know
it's a bunch of [ __ ] so um there's a
book called the erotic
mind by a guy named jack morin
and i read a long time ago but the thing
i remember is
is he says this very simple formula he
says attraction
plus an obstacle equals passion
and so you think about every
relationship every love story romeo and
juliet or whatever there's that initial
attraction and then there's a problem
there's a reason they can't
get there right the families won't let
him or it's a long distance thing or
she's already married
or it's two dudes and they're gay and
they can't tell anyone or
whatever it is there's always some
obstacle and so the
the attraction keeps building and
building to try to overcome that
obstacle
but once we remove the obstacle you get
together there's no obstacle anymore the
passion diminishes
and so it's weird it's like what are we
trying to do you meet somebody you're
really into
you want to be with them all the time
right so you're
sabotaging your own passion it's
interesting but
yeah anyway to get to his point i i
think it's really important to separate
those things so there's nothing wrong
with saying look i'm only i'm really
attracted to like you know
short blondes with you know big knees or
something but
don't mistake that for compatibility
right so you might find the perfect
short blonde with big knees
and that doesn't mean that you guys are
good together right
it just means you like looking at
pictures of her right yeah
i think that that if i were to sum up
what you're saying
there is is looks do matter in terms of
attraction but in terms of long-term
compatibility
maybe something like values matter you
know if
you have radically opposing values and
beliefs
even though you might be really
attracted to each other sexually right
yeah you might have a great sexual
encounter but but in terms of looking
for a long-term relationship that
thing's gonna fall apart and even worse
you're probably gonna stick it out
longer because of that
well the passion that you've just
described you might have kids
and by the time you figure out that
you're not a good
match for each other there are other
innocent people involved now
yeah that's the real tragedy i think
it's fine have a good time you're
attracted to a certain
type of person physically have a good
time but don't
mistake that for partnership for
compatibility and don't start
try to start a family with somebody
because you like the way she looks or he
looks yeah also you might have a type
right like you might have a type that
you're attracted to but that doesn't
mean that's the only type of person
you're attracted to so i mean
i think of bex my partner whom you met
when we were out your house and topanga
um and she is not my type at all
um but like in terms of like what i
would traditionally
date you know i used to date shorter
women and bex is
tall she's almost my height and
she has darker hair than what i would
date
normally and so like there are all these
things we were like well if i were to to
just pick what is my type it would
unlikely
be her um however i'm
still wildly attracted to her um not in
spite of her physical look she looks
gorgeous but realizing like there can be
a whole spectrum
of attractiveness as well i don't have
to just have the short blonde with the
big knees
i don't know what i'm allowed to say
yeah you could say whatever you want say
whatever you want
yeah and so what i realized though
with her is the thing that keeps me
attracted is the fact that we do
share so many similarities outside of uh
we yes we're attracted physically but
everything else beyond that sort of aids
the physical
attraction yeah yeah and i think that's
part of maturity too
i don't know how old this dude is but i
mean a lot of guys you know 20
22 23 24 like they're very
focused on the visual you know and
that's fine
you know experience those things but
don't
don't uh you know get yourself into a
situation that is going gonna have
long-term implications for
for other people then when you're in
your 30s maybe you will have matured
enough to be like hey
okay i've been there i've done that and
now i'm looking a little under the
surface i've had the short blonde with
the big knees
yeah yeah i've been down there right i
think it's cr i think it's crazy to say
that looks don't matter like i you know
you hear that
um kind of propagated it sounds virtuous
it does
on the surface yeah i'm i'm not shallow
at all
right but they matter for some things
and not for others right oh that's a
great way to put it yeah
yeah well i mean there there is
something
to be said about how we've evolved up to
this point too about how
uh these characteristics that we look
for it is
um almost a survival mechanism in a lot
of ways so
you know i think for that for that
aspect like it's kind of
um well it's it the cards are not
stacked
for us i mean they're stacked against us
when it comes to looks don't matter like
looks absolutely matter it's i think
it's programmed into our
into our dna i love what you said about
um
the uh uh love plus
an obstacle equals passion attraction
attraction yeah attraction plus
obstacles it's it's like almost
um kind of reiterates or affirms that
whole thing of you know it's not about
the destination it's about the journey
and uh looking at that specifically with
sex i mean it totally
makes sense so when you get into a
relationship where maybe you are
attracted to the person
drop dead gorgeous 10 years uh pass and
you get to this point where yes you're
comfortable
maybe you're not as you know sexually
attracted because of that familiarity
thing that we were talking about
um maybe you know to get over that hump
it is it's about
um putting in some type of obstacle or
putting in some type of
uh of excitement um i haven't got to
that point with mariah yet but it's
interesting because
if that's the equation for passion then
there are i feel like there are ways
that people who have been in
relationships for 20 years they can find
a way to maybe make an obstacle or make
something to
to create more passion in the
relationship vacation separately
yeah you know interesting miss each
other that is an interesting concept
it's like intermittent fasting right
yeah i mean really it's the same sort of
thing it's like you want to appreciate
your food more
be hungry
you